-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
In a new interview, the Russian
ambassador to the U.S.
said that he hasn't talked
to President Vladimir Putin
since 2017.
"Yes, you have,"
said a houseplant.
[ Laughter ]
After a federal judge
ruled yesterday
that the CDC mask mandate
on public transportation
was unlawful,
New York's MTA announced that it
will still enforce the mandate.
However, you are allowed
to briefly pull the mask down
to smoke weed on the subway car
during the morning rush hour.
[ Laughter ]
In a new special,
Fox News host Tucker Carlson
discussed a red-light therapy
called testicle tanning
that advocates claim
can raise testosterone levels.
Oh, I think there's a place
on the corner that does that.
[ Laughter ]
So you should stop by.
Pretty cool.
New York City, you know.
Tesla CEO Elon Musk said
in a new interview
that he does not own a home
and has just been staying
with friends.
Listen, we know you're lying.
You're a billionaire.
You don't have any friends.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Elon Musk says
that he does not own a home
and has just been staying
with friends.
Man, it's got to be pretty
galling to come home from work
and the world's richest man
is watching "Jeopardy!"
and eating your Cheerios.
[ Laughter ]
That's like Snoop coming over
to bum some weed.
[ Laughter ]
The "New York Daily News"
published an op-ed yesterday
by disgraced former governor
Andrew Cuomo,
though it was weird
he put that in his byline.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
a quarter of Americans
said that they would want
a professional biographer
to write the story
of their life,
while some literally
can't get them to stop.
[ Laughter ]
West Virginia senator
Joe Manchin
reportedly told a crowd
at a $5,000-a-plate fundraiser
last month
that he plans to run
for re-election in 2024.
Well, I should hope so.
Although it would be hilarious
to charge people $5,000
for a chicken cutlet
and then announce
your retirement.
[ Laughter ]
"Old Joe is goin' fishin'.
Enjoy the chicken, suckers."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new survey,
42% of Americans said
that if they had the chance
to meet their
favorite celebrity,
they would ask for a selfie,
or in my experience,
directions to Times Square.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, sure, anything,
anything for a fan.
Hey, while I'm here,
you want a selfie?
You don't.
Okay.
How about I take a picture
of you?
Just -- No?
Okay.
Right down there."
You guys,
that was the monologue.